hi everyone it's joanna here today's
workout will target your lower abs as
well as your love handles we know that
you can't burn belly fat by just doing
crunches all day long so this workout
will include ab movements as well as
cardio movements to increase fat burn so
let's get started
[Music]
so today i have wendy right here with me
she will be doing the regressive version
if you're a beginner you can follow
wendy okay so there will be a total of
four rounds each exercise will only be
for 30 seconds long so it's going to be
short and quick but i want you to really
feel your lower abs as well as your
obliques working so right let's get
straight into the workout sit on your
mat place your arms just right behind
you and the first exercise is going to
be detox so keep your legs straight okay
or beginner you can keep your knees back
keep a leg straight point your toes
forward only 30 seconds let's go
drive your legs straight up crunch up
and back down
so you should feel the work
on your lower abs good
and remember to breathe out
as you crunch up
good job
so for those of you who are new to this
movement you can do knee tucks just like
what wendy is doing
up
back down only 30 seconds up
down
up and down good
next movement is going to work on the
left handles russian twist so drive both
legs up place your hands together twist
side by side
again if you want an easier version what
you can do is place
both
feet down onto the floor so really twist
and feel the work
on your obliques
a few more
and
up
get straight up cross jacks okay this is
going to be your cardio so cross jacks
cross your toes cross your arms
for a low impact version
remove the jump
there you go
remember that you need to include cardio
exercises to increase fat burn okay you
cannot spot reduce fat
and
back down
take a short 30 seconds break
we want to repeat the entire round once
more and the first exercise is going to
be v-tucks okay so remember choose your
option either with your legs straight or
your knees bent so place both palms just
right behind you remember that your arms
are just supporting your upper body okay
the work should come from your lower abs
like straight
toes pointer forward are we ready let's
go up
down
up and down crunch
good job
if your legs are shaking
if your abs
is shaking
that's absolutely fine okay up
down
up
and down
good job
nice and controlled
movement
a few more
one more
and down
okay russian twist so from lower abs to
your obliques legs up
balance your legs arms up
and
twist
side to side
if this is too much
you can drop both
heels down
onto the floor
last few more
and down
okay get back up cross jacks okay so
remember cross
your toes
cross your arms
final 30 seconds
and this is
the end of round one and we're moving in
to the second round
looking strong
let's go
and
shake it out how are we doing feeling
good yes all right now let's get
straight down onto the mat and now let's
get it get ready for round two
lie onto the floor
relax your upper body
the next workout is going to be leg
raises okay so cable legs straight you
can place your palms directly
under your butt
just for a slight support all right
again this exercise works on your lower
abs bring it up
back down
and up
for an easier version remember to keep
your knees bent
up
and down
good job
nice and controlled movement
do not drop your heels
straight legs
as straight as you can
last one more
and up
get into a plank position we're going
for spiderman plank let's go high plank
drive your
knee towards your elbow
working on
your obliques
really push into the floor
knee to elbow
or you can choose to get
onto your knees for an easier version
and now get back up
30 seconds of cardio in out squat jump
tap
in
and tap
out there you go
stay light on your feet
in and out
or you can choose to remove the jump
just like what wender is doing
good job
five more seconds
and last one
good job
short to 30 seconds break okay let's get
down
on to the floor
back
onto
lying position
second round okay for this workout
leg raises so choose your option either
keep your knees bent or try to keep both
legs as straight as possible place your
palms directly under your butt
point
your toes
are we ready
let's go
down up
push lift your hips slightly off the
floor
for that extra squeeze on your lower abs
up
and down
back down
and up
good job
we're almost there
30 seconds is going by so quickly
that's one more and drop now straight
into spider-man plank no break right now
high plank position drive your elbow in
okay
good job
spread your palms
really push into the ground
knee towards your elbow
feel the squeeze
on your obliques
and come back
up okay
in and out squat jump are we ready let's
go tap
30 seconds of cardio
burst
and you'll be halfway
into this workout
keep going we're almost at the end
okay
and you'll be
halfway
through this workout
all right 30 seconds break two rounds
down two more to go okay
now let's
get down onto the mat the first exercise
for this round will be bicycle crunches
okay so imagine that you're cycling
but in a crunch position place both
arms just behind your ears or your head
but don't pull your head okay
lift your legs off the floor
and
crunch
to
the opposite
side
and rotate
and
look the opposite direction
so you should feel the work again
on
your obliques
and that's what we want
keep twisting
nice and controlled movement
do not just
rush through this workout okay point
straight legs
point
and point
oh my gosh
i can totally feel the burn okay
lie straight down
again you can choose to place both palms
directly under your butt
we're going for scissors
cross criss-cross all the way up
and
all the way down
criss-cross
and back down
do not rest
your heels right now
feel the burn
and
come back into a high plank position
cross climbers okay so instead of a
mountain climber
drive the opposite
knee to the opposite elbow ready
bring the speed up
and
run
keep
going driving the heart rate up
and rest
oh
30 seconds break
it's going to go by so quickly so let's
get down onto the mat
first exercise again
bicycle crunches okay
so
arms just directly behind your head
five seconds breather
and
in three two
one
straight legs let's go cross
[Music]
really maximize this
30 seconds okay i want to see
full
leg extension
keep going
point
and cross
that's one more and back down
okay love it or hit it let's go for
crisscross straight legs
criss-cross
all the way up
or you can follow wendy okay
just cross
all the way up
oh my gosh i can totally feel the burn
for this
up
back down
one more up
and just drop it down
all right high plank position
cross climber
ready let's go bring the speed up or go
slow
choose your option
okay
push it
climbing up that hill it's a very steep
hill but we're going to go right to the
top
[Music]
and drop your knees
take a short break if you want to get
into a child's pose
all right just breathe here
for 10 seconds
and we have one
final round
okay
just keep breathing
and the final round
get down onto the floor it's going to be
full alternate crunches so
use a little bit of momentum keep your
legs straight all i need to do is reach
up crunch up
release
and
crunch
good job
otherwise just drive one knee in at a
time reach
crunch
release
reach and crunch
good job don't just collapse reach
crunch really slow
crunch
one more
and crunch good job
all right
let's go
get into a plank position it's going to
be plank hip deep
solid back flat back dip your hip to
hips to the left
and to the right
okay maintaining a flat back
don't pike your butt
too high up
feel the work on your waist line
left and right
left and right okay and now let's get
back up
skate this okay it's going to be
challenging but find your balance
jump to the side on
to the opposite side or if you want to
remove the jump and just cross
your leg
directly behind the front leg
okay
keep going
five more seconds
three
two
one
and
30 seconds rest
we have one last round to go only 90
seconds left so let's get down
onto the floor
this is your final round so give me your
best effort okay if you want to
challenge yourself follow me
full alternate crunches
legs straight
arms straight out and as you come up
drive your left knee in and alternating
with your right knee ready up
there you go
feel the full crunch
on your abs
and as you drive your knee in
that's when you'll feel the extra work
on your lower abdominal muscles good job
remember don't just collapse your body
control it
down
[Music]
release
and
back
switch over
plank hip dip
get into
forearm plank
flat back ready down
feel the work
on your waistline
good job
gaze onto the floor
and pace your breathing i know it's
hurting but that's what we want
we're going to push ourselves through
every
workout session
and that's how we progress
and drop now final 30 seconds skaters we
got this okay start on one side let's go
hop
land gently
keeping your
knees bent
cross
good job
nice and graceful
just look at wendy she's making it look
so easy
last five seconds
that's two more
and break
well done high five
amazing amazing job if you're doing this
with a partner congratulate them on
pushing through the entire workout so
that was a quick 15 minute lower ab as
well as love handle workout and remember
to combine this workout with my other
total body strength training as well as
hit workouts and don't forget to also
hit the subscribe button like this video
and i will see you in my next workout
all the best
[Music]
you